MITCHELL OF TEXAS TECH
UNIVERSITY WHO TREATED
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH AT A
TIME.
FIRST, PETER NAVARRO.
WELCOME.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
I KNOW THAT YOU’RE ALL WORKING
VERY HARD TO GET EVERYBODY ON
TRACK.
ONE OF THE THINGS AT LEAST
PEOPLE SO UNNERVED IS THE IMPACT
THAT IT HAS ON THEIR DAILY LIFE
WITH REGARD TO WORK AND THEIR
JOB AND BEING ABLE TO GO TO WORK
AND ALL OF THAT.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
WAS PUT IN PLACE TODAY TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THAT ANXIETY.
>> MY JOB HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS TO BE A SOLDIER
OUT MAKING FOR THE SUPPLY CHAIN
WORKS SO THAT WE HAVE EVERYTHING
WE NEED TO TREAT OUR PEOPLE.
ONE OF THE THINGS I DID
YESTERDAY MORNING, I GOT A CALL
FROM A COMPANY THAT MAKES
ALCOHOL.
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
THEY HAD VOLUNTEERED TO MAKE
HAND SANITIZER USING THEIR
ALCOHOL.
THEY HAD SOME OBSTACLES.
I MADE THREE PHONE CALLS, ONE TO
TREASURY, WENT TO THE FDA IN ONE
TO HHS TO CLEAR THEIR OBSTACLES
OUT OF THE WAY.
TODAY WE GOT A COMMITMENT THAT
THEY WILL START PRODUCING ON
FRIDAY AT OVER TIME WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE 4,000 GALLONS A WEEK AND
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SEND IT TO THE GOVERNMENT AT NO
COST.
THAT IS THE KIND OF BEAUTY WE
ARE SEEING AS WE HAVE THE FULL
FORCE OF GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESS
JOINING HANDS TO HELP THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THESE FACILITIES ARE GOING TO BE
IN AMERICA.
THEY ARE IN WEST VIRGINIA,
ARKANSAS, TEXAS AND KENTUCKY.
>> Martha: I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS, IT’S MAKING A LOT OF US
THINK ABOUT, THE SUPPLY CHAIN
EIGHT.
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT’S VERY
CONCERNING IS THE AMOUNT OF OUR
MEDICINE AND PHARMACEUTICALS
THAT WE HAVE HANDED OVER TO THE
CHINESE TO PRODUCE.
I KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT TO YOU AS WELL.
HOW QUICKLY CAN WE RAMP UP THAT
PRODUCTION HERE AT HOME?
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
>> I WILL GIVE YOU ANOTHER
EXAMPLE.
HONEYWELL OFFERED ON FRIDAY,
CALL MY OFFICE AND SAID WE WANT
TO START PRODUCING WITHIN 30
DAYS THE FACE MASKS.
WE CAN OPEN UP OF PLANT IN
SMITHFIELD RHODE ISLAND.
ALL WE NEED TO DO IS, IF YOU
HELP US WORK WITH HHS TO GET THE
BALL ROLLING.
SO ON FRIDAY, I SAID OKAY, GET
YOUR CONTRACTED AND THEY GUIDED
IN.
I CALLED HHS AND SAID WE ARE
GOING TO FLIP IT.
IN A COUPLE DAYS.
ALREADY WE HAVE HONEYWELL MOVING
TOWARDS THAT.
SO WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IS HAVING
THE APPROPRIATE INCENTIVE FOR
OUR DOMESTIC INDUSTRY TO PRODUCE
THESE THINGS LIKE FACE MASKS AND
HAND SANITIZER AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED.
WHAT WE NEED LONG TERM, THIS THE
PROBLEM THAT WE FACE.
THE GOVERNMENT DOES NOT BUY
AMERICAN ENOUGH.
THE GOVERNMENT, VA, HHS, DOD,
TREMENDOUSLY LARGE CONSUMERS OF
MEDICINE, MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
PRESIDENT AS WE SPEAK TO GET AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO THE FINISH
LINE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
LONG-TERM INCENTIVES FOR OUR
COMPANIES TO PRODUCE HERE.
IT’S NOT ABOUT CHINA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DISPERSION OF
THAT CHAIN, IT’S ACROSS THE
WORLD.
EUROPE FOR EXAMPLE, IRELAND
SURPRISINGLY ENOUGH, GERMANY,
SWITZERLAND, HEAVILY DEPENDENT
ON THEM.
INDIA AS WELL.
WHAT WE’VE GOT TO DO IS THREE
THINGS.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE BUY
AMERICAN.
WE ARE GOING TO DEREGULATE SO WE
CAN GET THINGS DONE FASTER.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, WE ARE
GOING TO INNOVATE TO KEEP PRICES
DOWN.
THERE IS A PROCESS CALLED
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING THAT WE
ARE WORKING LIGHTNING SPEED TO
GET SWITCH IS FLIPPED ON.
THAT’S THE BIG PICTURE.
WE CANNOT KEEP HAVING THESE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES AND GO BACK
TO SLEEP LIKE THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
THIS TIME AND WE ARE GOING TO
GET THROUGH THIS AND WE ARE
GOING TO BE IN A BETTER PLACE
OVER TIME BECAUSE WE ARE GOING
TO PRODUCE THINGS HERE IN
AMERICA.
>> Martha: THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WHAT ABOUT THE CURRENT CONCERNS
OVER ENOUGH BEDS, ENOUGH
HOSPITAL FACILITIES, THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
SHOULD BE BUILDING TEMPORARY
HOSPITALS AND MEDICAL
FACILITIES.
WE HEARD GOVERNOR CUOMO SAYING
IN SOME CASES YOU CAN MOVE SOME
PEOPLE OUT OF OUR HOSPITALS
WHERE THE HEAVIER EQUIPMENT IS.
IF THEY ARE IN A HEALTHIER
SITUATION, NOT DEALING WITH
COVID-19, MAYBE SOME OF THEM
COULD BE MOVED INTO TEMPORARY
FACILITIES.
WHERE IS THE PROGRESS ON THAT?
>> MARTHA, IT’S NOT REALLY MY
LANE ON THAT.
>> Martha: I UNDERSTAND.
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS
THERE’S QUICK ACTION WITHIN THE
PENTAGON WORKING WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THOSE KIND OF
THINGS.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS ON
SATURDAY, I GOT ANOTHER CALL
WHERE HE HAD TO GET SOME SWABS
FOR TESTING OVER FROM EUROPE
HERE AND WE GOT THE PENTAGON
BASICALLY TO SEND A FLIGHT TO
WHERE WE NEEDED, FEDEX
VOLUNTEERED SOME OF ITS OWN
DELIVERY PLATES.
THAT PLANE LANDED, MILITARY
PLANE LANDED IN MEMPHIS.
FEDEX PICKED THEM UP AND WE WERE
ABLE TO DISPERSE 850,000 SWABS
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
>> Martha: THAT’S GOOD.
SPEAK OF THE PENTAGON IS ENGAGED
AND WE ARE ENGAGED.
>> Martha: LAST QUESTION, THE
BIG PICTURE.
IN TERMS OF THE NATIONAL
ANXIETY, WHAT IS THE MOOD AT THE
WHITE HOUSE ON HOW TO APPROACH
IT?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT’S GOING
TO HAPPEN WITH ALL THE
ADDITIONAL SWABS AND ADDITIONAL
TESTING IS SOMETHING WE’VE ALL
SAID AND THAT WE KNOW BUT WHEN
YOU SEE IT HAPPENING IT’S
UNNERVING AND THAT’S A BIG
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
POSITIVES.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO HELP
PEOPLE WITH THE ANXIETY OF THE
RISING NUMBERS?
>> WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY A WARTIME
PRESIDENT NOW IN THE WAR IS
AGAINST THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE NEED TO FLATTEN THE CURVE.
WE ARE CONFIDENT WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, DOING WHAT THE CDC
RECOMMENDS, WITH GOVERNMENT AND
BUSINESS, THAT WE ARE GOING TO
GET THROUGH THIS TO THE OTHER
SIDE.
WE ARE VERY STRONG PEOPLE.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS, WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
WORKING 24/7 EITHER HERE OR
THROUGH TELECOMMUTING.
IT’S GOING TO BE FINE.
WE’VE JUST GOT TO WORK TO GET
THIS THROUGH.
EVERYBODY’S GOT TO PULL
TOGETHER.
THERE CAN’T BE ANY DISSENSION IN
THE RANKS.
THE OTHER BIG THING, I’VE GOT TO
SAY.
WE’VE GOT TO GET THAT
$1.2 TRILLION STIMULUS THROUGH
IN A MATTER OF DAYS, NOT WEEKS
OR MONTHS.
THAT HAS TO HAPPEN NOW.
WE KNOW WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TREMENDOUS HEADWINDS IN THE
SECOND QUARTER.
WE NEED TO GET THROUGH THAT AND
HAVE A GOOD BOUNCE BACK.
WE NEED $1.2 TRILLION THE
PRESIDENT IS ASKING FOR THAT.
THERE IS BASICALLY SUPPORT FOR
THAT ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
EXACTLY THAT LOOKS LIKE.
I AM TELLING YOU, DAYS NOT
WEEKS.
GET IT DONE.
>> Martha: THE CASH THAT GOES
BACK INTO PEOPLE’S POCKETS, THE
TREASURY SECRETARY TALKING ABOUT
IT TODAY, WHEN THEY DON’T HAVE
ANYWHERE DISTENDED, HOW
CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT THAT’S
GOING TO PROVIDE A STIMULUS?
NO RESTAURANTS, MOVIE THEATERS,
BROADWAY SHOWS, WHERE DOES THE
MONEY GO?
>> THERE’S A NUMBER OF OPTIONS
ON THE TABLE.
ONE IS A PAYROLL TAX CUT WHICH
WOULD BE A SUSTAINED LEVEL OF
SUPPORT THROUGH THE END OF THE
YEAR.
THE OTHER IS THE INSTANT
REBATES.
THERE’S A LOT OF THINGS IN
BETWEEN.
HERE’S THE THING.
I’VE ADVOCATED A MULTIFACTOR
APPROACH WE HAVE A TARGETED
RELIEF PROGRAM LIKE THE PELOSI
BILL WAS PASSED WHERE YOU HELPED
-- YOU DON’T WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE
A CHOICE OF GOING TO WORK SICK
OR STAYING HOME BROKE.
THAT’S ONE VECTOR.
YOU HAVE THE FISCAL STIMULUS.
1.2 TRILLION.
SOME FORM OF THAT.
YOU HAVE WITH THE FED DID WITH
LOWERING INTEREST RATES BUT ALSO
OPENING THE WINDOW TO EMERGENCY
LENDING.
WE NEED TO DO THAT.
AND THEN YOU NEED THE INDUSTRY
ASSISTANCE.
SO IF YOU DO ALL FOUR OF THOSE
THINGS.
I HAVE TO STRESS.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND YOU
CAN’T JUST DO ONE OF THOSE
THINGS OR TWO OF THOSE THINGS.
YOU NEED ALL FOUR POINTS.
THE PRESIDENT IS ADAMANT ABOUT
THIS AND IF WE DO IT IN DAYS
WILL BE FINE ECONOMICALLY.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THAT’S WHY I’M WORKING ON THE